we know everyone is unique in their own
special way but sometimes even celebs
end up looking a lot alike some stars
resent their doppelgangers while others
have embraced the fact that their
accidentally twinning Kiernan Shipka was
even mistaken for another actress on her
own Instagram page it's a long story
right in order to you probably know
actress victoria justice from her time
as Tori Vega on Nickelodeon's victorious
but did you know that she has a
look-alike or rather she has at least
one look-alike because a lot of fans
happen to think that Victoria could be
sisters with the Vampire Diaries actress
Nina Dobrev these two have super similar
shaped faces and styled their hair in
similar ways and this resemblance isn't
just a recent development Victoria and
Nina even look alike in their childhood
photos yeah guess which celebrity R now
let's throw a third celeb in the mix
model Melanie Iglesias and yes these
ladies know all about their resemblance
and they're only too happy to strike a
pose with each other if their goal was
to look alike let's just say all three
of them are victorious and not just
Victoria I didn't tell you I never told
you I was faking you guessed it here at
the things you know we love our Disney
Channel stars both the current ones and
ones from way back when so naturally we
couldn't help but think that we'd seen
actor Timothy sha'lame somewhere before
he's been in movies like Little Women
and the king and his classic good looks
and curly hair remind us of Lizzie's BFF
Gordo
from Lizzie McGuire okay so it's been a
long time since Adam Lambert was on the
small screen but the resemblance between
them is undeniable and if you're missing
Lizzie McGuire we have some good news
it's coming back along with Adam himself
since all of our favorite characters are
all grown up this makes total sense but
a Disney ever decides to do a remake of
the original series they should
definitely consider hiring Timothy as
gordo actress dove Cameron is known for
playing twins Liv and Maddie on the
Disney show of the same name but did you
know she has a twin in real life too
okay so she's not actually related to
Australian model Miranda Kerr but you
got to admit they look a lot of life
Miranda may have styled herself as a
brunette most of the time but she and
dove have extremely similar facial
structures
those high cheekbones and those gorgeous
blue eyes are impossible to hide and
make them look like sisters you might be
wondering if Devin Miranda know about
their similarities and we know that at
the very least Dov certainly does and
she seems to be flattered by the
comparison sometimes I seriously
question it Selena Gomez may have been
named after the legendary singer Selena
but she looks even more like another
star she is usually 20 with Pretty
Little Liars star Lucy Hale whether she
means to or not in fact according to
Lucy she's actually been mistaken for
Selena Gomez before and more than once
Lucy says that when she was younger she
used to be confused with Selena when she
was starring in Wizards of Waverly Place
usually Lucy would correct confused fans
but not always
after taking a quick pic with a fan she
realized they had mistaken her for
Selena and she was too embarrassed to
set the record straight and Selena isn't
the only star fans think Lucy looks like
power came back on and every single
person on that train was staring at me
despite her fame does Lucy have just one
of those faces because according to her
she gets mistaken for other stars all
the time
she says that she shares a similar vibe
with Sarah Hyland from Modern Family
Game of Thrones star Maisie Williams
vocs rachel bilson honestly we can kind
of see it Lucy believes it's because
they're petite women with big eyes but
there's one more star we think should be
added to the mix the foster star Maia
Mitchell looks a lot like Lacey too and
the two were even here twins at the 2015
Teen Choice Awards even when they wear
their hair down
there's no denying the resemblance
between these two we promise we're not
just comparing these two stars because
they share the same name although come
on what are the odds of that
when Demi Lovato showed up to the 2017
MTV EMA's in a sleek plaid suit many
fans thought that her red-carpet look
was taken straight from Demi Moore in
fact some were a little too convinced
there had to be a connection between
them and started a rumor that Demi Moore
is Demi Lovato's mom sorry to disappoint
but that's simply not true
Demi Moore has three kids and none of
them are named Demi still these two look
a lot alike with their long hair similar
facial structure and stunning physiques
some things I'm such as
but you can't buy people speaking of
celebs who appear alike on paper we have
euphoria actress and daya and singer
Cassie both prefer to go by a mononym
rather than their full names and the
similarities don't end there
when zendaya posted a pic of them
together on her Instagram some fans even
thought the two of them were actual
sisters both Cassie and zendaya make
looking fabulous and flowing fabrics
look effortless and they're not afraid
to play around with bold colors and
silhouettes when you see them head-on or
from the side it can be hard to tell
them apart at first glance since Emily
Ratajkowski and Kendall Jenner are both
wildly successful fashion models maybe
it's not too surprising that they look a
lot alike of course we all know there's
a strong family resemblance among the
kardashian-jenner z-- but Emily's name
doesn't even start with a k' making this
set of celebrity twins all the more
impressive at the 2018 Versace Milan
Fashion Week their similarity
silhouettes on the catwalk were
absolutely undeniable their eyebrows
were sculpted into similar shapes and
their high cheekbones and narrow faces
make them look like they could be
related not only do they physically
resemble each other but they tend to
style themselves similarly too it can be
hard to tell if you're looking at a
picture of Emily or one of Kendall for
instance did you notice that we mixed
those last two picks up uh-huh pulling
fans is one thing but sometimes even the
celebrities themselves can't tell the
difference
like when Riverdale actress Lilly
Reinhardt saw this picture of herself
and Game of Thrones star Kidd Harrington
in the movie the death and life of John
abdon 'van the only problem Lilly wasn't
in that movie instead it was true
detectives actress Sarah Gadon in that
picture a fact it took Lilly a little
while to realize Lilly's also been
compared to late actress Brittany Murphy
but we think that besides Sarah Gadon
she looks the most like Elizabeth whale
who played one of your back on you it's
all the yoga it keeps me young
everyone knows models Bella Hadid and
Gigi Hadid are siblings and there's
definitely a family resemblance going on
there but weirdly enough we think Bella
actually looks more like Hunger Games
star Jennifer Lawrence than her own
sister and apparently we're not alone
because according to Bella she gets this
all the time when she first started out
she'd hear the comparison five times a
day from various sources but maybe the
craziest part of this is that Bella
doesn't see
although it's certainly flattering to be
compared to an academy award-winning
actress like Jennifer Bella just doesn't
think there are enough similarities
between them do you think she has a
point or is this star way off-base you
might know actress Kiernan Shipka from
her work on chilling Adventures of
Sabrina but apparently not everyone does
that's because a fan commented on photo
of her on her own Instagram mistaking
her for beauty of the beast actress Emma
Watson whoops
these two stars definitely don't need a
Polyjuice potion to play up their
similarities they shared the same strong
and distinguishable brow style as well
as brown almond eyes Emma and Kiernan
both started out as child stars and as
they get older they keep looking more
and more alike they're both fashionable
fabulous and dog lovers earlier we
mentioned that Lucy Hale thinks that she
shares a similar vibe with Modern Family
star Sarah Hyland but we think that
there's a fellow celeb who Sarah
resembles even more and that is
forgetting sarah marshall actress mila
kunis the resemblance between the two of
them is so strong that they pretty much
have to have noticed it by now it turns
out that these stars are well aware of
their similarities since they cause some
awkward encounters from time to time
Mila told Sarah that she's used to
getting compliments on her work on
Modern Family and Sarah even asked if
she's allowed to pretend to be me lat -
Sarah's even been called the name on the
red carpet which can be a little awkward
Sarah says that she wasn't sure if she
should gently correct the reporter at
the 2010 Golden Globes or if she should
have just referenced Milla's role in
Black Swan by yelling Natalie Portman's
a bad kisser Bella Thorne and Jessica
Chastain have totally leaned into the
fact that they look alike Jessica even
joked on her own Instagram that she is
pretty much the afterimage of Bella's
tenure challenge these two look great
together and they work well together too
they both appeared in the death and life
of John F Donna Ben and could not stop
complimenting each other's looks and
talent these two can't say enough nice
things about each other which takes the
awesomeness of their twinning to the
next level at first it seems impossible
that someone wouldn't want to be
compared to the stunning birds of prey
actress Margot Robbie but Emma Mackie
has a good reason for not wanting to
dwell on her doppelganger according to
Emma she doesn't see a resemblance at
all and she doesn't like discussing it
instead she wants to talk about their
talent and the projects they've worked
on instead of what they happen to look
like although most of us probably
disagree with them as assessment on
their similarities we can't fault her
for not wanting to talk about it so
let's take a look at my name is Earl
Starr Jaime Pressly who has totally
embraced being compared to Margot
these are definitely three of the most
dissimilar looking stars in Hollywood
it's no secret that the Hemsworth
brothers Chris Luke and Liam resemble
one another but that's not exactly
surprising what is surprising is that
there someone' Liam looks like even more
than his actual siblings just take a
look at Liam compared to Russian tennis
player Karan hai Chenab their bone
structures look a lot of light and
they're almost identical facial hair
really seals the deal if Liam wore
tennis uniform and Corinne put on a suit
it would be hard to tell them apart
perfect let's get some coffee actually
what do you do take a seat pal you'll
find out they say everyone has a twin
out there do you know of any celebrity
look-alikes that we may have missed
share your finds with us and your fellow
fans in the comments section below and
don't forget to click on that subscribe
button for more new videos from us here
at the things thanks for watching and
we'll see you again next time